ABOUT THE PARKLAND MASSACRE
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
AS WE DOCUMENTED LAST NIGHT,
THE STUDENT WALKOUT FOR GUN
CONTROL YESTERDAY LOOKED AT
TIMES MORE LIKE A POLITICAL
CELEBRATION THAN A SOMBER
PROTEST.
WITH LEFT WING POLITICIANS
GREETED LIKE ROCK STARS.
LOOK AT HOW THE CROWD
GATHERED AT THE U.S. CAPITOL
WITH THEIR SELFIE STICKS IN
HAND GREETED BERNIE SANDERS
AS HE MADE HIS WAY TO THE
BLOW HORN.
OH MY GOD, THEY WERE GOING
NUTS.
IT WAS PURE PARTISAN
POLITICS.
IT WAS SCRIPTED AND
SCREAMED.
AND WHY AM I SAYING THAT?
BECAUSE.
>> BECAUSE IT IS NOT SIMPLY
ABOUT GUN CONTROL ANYMORE.
OH, HERE.
>> BECAUSE -- WAIT.
OKAY.
BECAUSE IT IS NOT SIMPLY
ABOUT GUN CONTROL.
THIS IS ABOUT HUMAN LIFE.
THIS IS ABOUT THE CHILDREN
WHO HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES TO
GUN VIOLENCE.
SO I ASK OUR REPUBLICAN
LAWMAKERS, IS THEIR RIGHT TO
HAVE A GUN MORE IMPORTANT
THAN OUR RIGHT TO LIVE?
[CHEERS]
>> Laura: NOT PARTISAN AT
ALL.
LOOK, THAT'S A NICE APPLAUSE
LINE.
BUT, OF COURSE, THE WRATH OF
THE STUDENTS IS MISDIRECTED.
THE LINES ARE SHOUTING MANY
USED REPEATEDLY OVER THE
YEARS BY ANTIGUN ACTIVISTS
CONVENIENTLY DO NOT ADDRESS
THE REAL PROBLEM WITH THAT
HORRIFIC TRAGEDY AT STONEMAN
DOUGLAS HIGH.
THE NRA IS NOT RESPONSIBLE
FOR ALLOWING NIKOLAS CRUZ TO
BE ARMED AND DANGEROUS.
NEITHER ARE REPUBLICAN
POLITICIANS THAT YOUNG LADY
JUST CALLED OUT WHO SUPPORT
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS FOR
LAW ABIDING AMERICANS.
A NEW SURVEILLANCE VIDEO
JUST RELEASED BY COURT ORDER
CONFIRMS WHAT WE ALREADY
KNEW.
DUE TO MALFEASANCE,
COWARDICE, OR JUST PURE POOR
JUDGMENT, THE FIRST OFFICER
ON THE SCENE, BROWARD DEPUTY
SCOTT PETERSON, DID NOT
ENTER BUILDING 1200 WHERE
CRUZ WAS CARRYING OUT HIS
SLAUGHTER.
HE ARRIVED ON A GOLF CART.
YOU SEE HIM THERE, WITH
STAFF MEMBERS WHILE THE
MASSACRE WAS UNDERWAY.
IN THE VIDEO SHOWS PETERSON
WITH HIS GUN DRAWN BUT THEN
HE STEPS BACK AND HE REMAINS
OUTSIDE.
HE STOOD THERE AS NIKOLAS
CRUZ'S SIX MINUTE SPREE OF
SHOOTING CONTINUED.
WELL, IN A STATEMENT,
PETERSON'S LAWYER CLAIMED
THE DEPUTY THOUGHT THE SHOTS
WERE BEING FIRED OUTSIDE.
BUT THESE RADIO
COMMUNICATIONS RELEASED LAST
WEEK DEMONSTRATE HE KNEW THE
SHOTS WERE COMING FROM
INSIDE BUILDING 1200.
SHOTS FIRED.
1200 BUILDING.
WE ALSO HEARD IT OVER INSIDE
BY THE 1200 BUILDING.
BROWARD DO NOT APPROACH THE
12 OR 1300 BUILDING.
STAY ALEAST 500 FEET AWAY AT
THIS POINT.
>> Sean: WOW, AS WE WILL
DISCUSS IN A MOMENT,
PETERSONEN OR NONE OF THE
OTHER THREE OFFICERS ON
SCENE FOLLOWED POLICE
PROTOCOL.
REMEMBER WHAT BROWARD
SHERIFF SCOTT ISRAEL, THAT
NUMBER SAID, WHEN HE WAS
PRESSED ABOUT PETERSON'S
RESPONSE?
>> I GAVE HIM A GUN.
I GAVE HIM A BADGE.
I GAVE HIM THE TRAINING.
IF HE DIDN'T HAVE THE HEART
TO GO IN, THAT'S NOT MY
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> Laura: SO MUCH FOR THE
BUCK STOPPING AT THE TOP.
ISRAEL, I KNOW IT SOUNDS
TOUGH HERE, BUT, HE COMES
OFF AS A SLIMY
SELF-PROMOTER.
AND THE STORIES OVER THE
YEARS ABOUT HOW HE HAS HIRED
HIS FRIENDS AND HIS FAMILY
IN KEY POSITIONS, REPORTEDLY
MANY OF THEM NOT QUALIFIED
AFTER HE WAS ELECT YOU HAD.
AND THIS IS THE SAME GUY, BY
THE WAY, SHERIFF ISRAEL, WHO
THOUGHT IT WAS APPROPRIATE
TO OPINE ON A CNN TOWN HALL
JUST A WEEK AFTER THE
SHOOTING.
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING THE
INVESTIGATION.
HE IS ON TV.
OF COURSE, WHEN HE WAS ON
TV, HE DID NOT EVEN MENTION
THE FAILURE OF SCOTT
PETERSON ON SCENE.
LOOK, MANY OF THOSE
ADVOCATING FOR GUN CONTROL
POST PARKLAND, THEY WANT TO
LOOK AWAY FROM THE ERRORS
COMMITTED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHICH WERE NUMEROUS AND
FRANKLY OBSCENE AT BOTH THE
FEDERAL AND THE STATE LEVEL.
THERE IS ALMOST NO
DISCUSSION AT YESTERDAY'S
RALLIES MENTIONING NIKOLAS
CRUZ'S DANGEROUS BEHAVIOR
WAS FLAGGED REPEATEDLY TO
AUTHORITIES OVER TWO YEARS.
STARTING IN FEBRUARY OF
2016.
NOW, JUST A FEW REMINDERS
BECAUSE WE FORGET THIS STUFF
AFTER A MONTH.
ON FEBRUARY 5TH, 2016,
BROWARD POLICE IS TOLD BY AN
ANONYMOUS CALLER THAT
NIKOLAS CRUZ HAD THREATENED
TO SHOOT UP HIS SCHOOL AND
POSTED A PHOTO OF HIMSELF
WITH GUNS ON INSTAGRAM.
THE INFO WAS PROVIDED TO
DEPUTY SCOTT PETERSON.
THEN ON SEPTEMBER 28TH,
2016, AN INVESTIGATOR FOR
THE FLORIDA DEPARTMENT OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
CONCLUDES AFTER A VISIT THAT
CRUZ IS STABLE, DESPITE
FINDING FRESH CUTS ON HIS
ARMS, APPARENTLY
SELF-INFLICTED.
HIS MOTHER LINDA CRUZ SAID
HE HAD RECENTLY SPOKEN OF
BUYING WEAPONS.
THEN, ON SEPTEMBER 24TH,
2017, A YOUTUBE USER NAMED
NIKOLAS CRUZ POSTS A COMMENT
STATING HE WANTS TO BECOME,
QUOTE:  A PROFESSIONAL
SCHOOL SHOOTER.
THE FBI AND MISSISSIPPI
HEARS OF THIS BUT FAILS TO
MAKE THE CONNECTION TO
FLORIDA.
THEN, THERE WAS THIS.
A FEW WEEKS AFTER HIS MOTHER
DIED, ON NOVEMBER 29TH,
2017, THE PALM BEACH COUNTY
FAMILY THAT TOOK CRUZ IN,
AFTER HIS MOTHER'S DEATH
CALLED THE PALM BEACH
SHERIFF'S OFFICE TO REPORT A
FIGHT BETWEEN CRUZ AND THEIR
SON.
>> HE BOUGHT A GUN ABOUT A
WEEK AND A HALF AGO AND HE
TODAY -- GOING THERE NOW.
THAT'S ALL YOU WANT WITH HIS
GUN AND THAT'S ALL HE CARES
ABOUT IS HIS GUN.
HE BOUGHT TONS OF BULLETS
AND STUFF AND I TOOK IT AWAY
FROM HIM AND I HAVE A BUNCH
OF OTHER LITTLE GUNS HERE.
BB GUNS THOUGH.
HE HAS REAL GUNS HE IS GOING
TO GET NOW.
>> Laura: THEN SHE MENTIONS
SPECIFIC THREATS HE HAD
MADE.
>>
MADE
>> Laura: IT'S UNBELIEVABLE
TO HEAR THIS.
THEN THERE WERE TWO OTHER
CALLS.
ONE TO BROWARD THE NEXT DAY
AND ONE TO THE FBI ON
JANUARY 5TH OF THIS YEAR
TAGGING CRUZ AGAIN AS A
POTENTIAL SCHOOL SHOOTER.
NEITHER BROWARD NOR THE FBI
FOLLOWED UP.
SO, WHILE EVERYBODY IS
DENOUNCING THE NRA OR
TRASHING PRESIDENT TRUMP IN
THE WAKE OF THE SICKENING
SCHOOL SHOOTING, ACTIVISTS
MIGHT THINK THAT ALTHOUGH
IT'S FUN TO GET THE COVERAGE
OPT EVENING NEWS OR BE THE
SUBJECT OF AN EXCITING VIRAL
VIDEO FOR YOUR SPEECH IN
FRONT OF THE CAPITOL, YOU'RE
ONLY HURTING YOUR OWN CAUSE
IF YOU REFUSE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE, REALLY FOCUS ON
THE FACT THAT WE ACTUALLY
DIDN'T NEED NEW LAWS TO STOP
CRUZ.
WE NEEDED TO FOLLOW THE
PROPER POLICING ON THE STATE
AND FEDERAL LEVELS BECAUSE
HAD THOSE -- THAT POLICY,
THOSE PROTOCOLS ACTUALLY
BEEN CONDUCTED, CRUZ WOULD
HAVE BEEN PREVENTED FROM
CARRYING OUT THE PARKLAND
CARNAGE.
HE PROBABLY WOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO GET A GUN IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
SHERIFF SCOTT ISRAEL, AFTER
ALL OF THIS, LOOK, HE SHOULD
HAVE PACKED HIS DESK AS SOON
AS HE LEARNED OF DEPUTY
PETERSON'S FAILURE ON HIS
WATCH.
THE SHOOTER WAS NOT
CONFRONTED IN THE BUILDING.
INSTEAD OF PASSING THE BUCK
AND GRANT STANDING AGAINST
THE NRA, THAT'S WHAT A GOOD